the british ceo of a fortune 100 company
is very upset that the voters of georgia
through their elected representatives
are trying to protect their elections
he's really upset about this
and he's going to do everything he can
to stop it let me be crystal clear and
unequivocal
this legislation is unacceptable
it is a step backwards and it does not
promote principles we have stood for in
georgia
around broad access to voting around
voter convenience
about ensuring election uh integrity and
this is this is frankly just a step
backwards
we've spent many decades uh promoting
uh within georgia a better society and a
better environment for business and this
is a step backwards and we're very clear
on that
and our position remains the same uh
this legislation
uh is wrong and needs to be remedied and
we will continue to advocate for it
uh both in private uh and now uh even
more clearly in public
that's what we will do fellow americans
yes we will because we're all americans
here we're all residents of atlanta and
georgia
and that's what he's my turns out that
he's michael cain that's the closest
that he's got
uh really not helping his case and
really not a compelling argument
when multinational corporations
are coming in and it's i'm not even just
talking about coca-cola there are a
bunch of these corporations
going in and saying that the voters of
georgia have no right
to protect their elections this guy's
got every right i suppose
to lobby in the public certainly maybe
in private too
and the georgia representatives have
every right to punish
coca-cola for trying to undermine their
government for undermining their
politics it is long
past time that republicans stopped
harping on abstract economic theories
and started talking about old-time
politics particularly when it comes to
the corporations that hate us
i'm michael knowless the michael knowles
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm just warning you now this show is
gonna have a lot of funny accents
there's
there's no way around it the coca-cola
guy just the tip of the iceberg
my favorite comment yesterday from
audrey who says i love how proud michael
looks of himself
when he transitions into and out into an
ad
i am proud i am proud when i can
transition
into an atom i'm almost as proud as i as
i feel
when i remember that i've protected my
family with ready wise ready wise is the
leader in emergency
food supplies emergency meals freeze
dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient on the go nutrition and
new adventure meals for hiking camping
and other outdoor activities
ready wise makes being prepared simple
and affordable order online
have nutritious meals shipped directly
to your doorstep ready-wise products are
proudly made in the usa
when preparing ready-wise meals all you
need is four cups of water the water
doesn't even need to be hot you just
pour the food into the water
stir and cover after about 15 minutes
the meal is ready some meals
can even be prepared directly in the
pouch which eliminates the need for
additional supplies
to me it's just peace of mind okay
you get ready wise it's really top of
their game you know terrific product
you put it away if you need it in an
emergency you're good if the last year
and a half hasn't taught you to be
prepared for an emergency
i just don't know what will this week my
listeners can get 10 off at
readywise.com
when entering knowles 10 at checkout or
by calling 855
three twenty nine forty five ready wise
has a 30 day no questions asked return
policy
there is no risk whatsoever in taking
the initiative to get you and your
family prepared today that is
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e
dot com promo code no stand to get 10
off not just coca-cola
that is trying to undermine election
integrity in the united states american
airlines
which is based in fort worth american
airlines has come out against
voting legislation that was passed by
the texas senate
to protect the integrity of those
elections
american airlines says to make american
stance clear
the answer to a question nobody asked we
are strongly opposed to this bill
and others like it what's going on here
what's going on in texas what's going on
in georgia what's going on in other
places
is that all around this country
leftist activists overturned
election integrity measures in 2020 and
they used the virus as the excuse to do
it
in some cases in many cases they
violated the law in some cases they
violated the state constitution to do it
and so now
after the unbelievable
nonsense that went on during those
elections the outrageous power grabs
the the the collapse of voter integrity
measures
people are going in and saying now we
get we got to make sure
that you don't try to steal elections
because
political parties and notably the
democrats have stolen elections by
stuffing ballot boxes for a long time
this was outlined in in excruciating
detail by robert carro
in his description of the 1948 senate
election in texas
involving lyndon johnson gave us
president johnson eventually
they do this a lot and so we need we
need to protect the ballot
because you know when when someone is
not permitted to vote
if that person is eligible to vote
that's a big problem
but when an ill ineligible voter votes
in in both of those cases a vote from a
legitimate voter is taken away
it's not the only way to take away a
vote from a legitimate voter if you
prevent him from voting you can also
just enfranchise
an ineligible voter that accomplishes
the same
end so what is the texas legislature
going to do here
what i think they should do is punish
american airlines
the uh well i think the old school
republican view of this would be yes
punish companies that are trying to
subvert your republic but then over the
last 20 years
the republican party has gone stupid and
the conservative movement even has
really atrophied
and the conservative movement has become
little more than shills for
giant corporations that hate us and it's
because of
of some misbegotten principle that
conservatives are never supposed to use
political power and we're supposed to
let
corporations run our our country it's
because i don't know because
too many conservative movement leaders
read ein rand or something
and forgot that there is actually a
political tradition here
and if if the woke-ism and the upending
of our culture is being pushed by
corporations
that's really no better in the end than
if it's being pushed by big government
or something else like that
so i think the texas legislature i don't
know what kind of tax breaks american
airlines gets
i bet they get some pretty significant
ones the texas legislature should go in
and strip them of those tax breaks
they should go in with the punitive
purpose
of preventing a very powerful company
like american airlines
from subverting the electoral process
same thing going on back in georgia with
with delta
delta ceo ed bastian
one of the woker of the airline ceos
he said that the the new election law in
georgia does not match delta's values
so delta does not value protecting the
ballot box in georgia that's okay
doesn't
the the protection of american elections
does not match delta's values delta has
very close ties to the chinese communist
party delta
in 2015 bought a three and a half
percent stake a little bit more than
that actually
in china eastern airlines which is a
state airline
purchased that for almost half a billion
dollars
so the chinese communist party
and the policies associated with it
for instance the genocide of the uyghur
minority the long-standing though
fortunately now
seems to have gone by the wayside policy
of one child
on and on and on that very much in line
with delta's values
china our number one geopolitical
adversary so supporting our number one
enemy
that goes along with delta's values but
protecting the ballot box in georgia
does not georgia
should strip delta of its tax breaks
and they're they're moving to do that
right now so the georgia state house
passed an amendment
that would strip delta of a
multi-million dollar tax break
they've done this before delta has
weathered it
i don't know how well they could weather
these sorts of things right now because
the airlines are hemorrhaging cash
but it even this sort of thing this
punishment of not of losing your tax
break
has not worked very well in the past
this is not a mere political
disagreement
meaning uh this is this is not an
ordinary disagreement over well you want
more immigrants i want fewer immigrants
you want higher taxes i want lower taxes
you support this kind of funding for
this project i support this thing
even you support this view of marriage i
support this view of marriage this goes
deeper
this is the people of georgia are saying
we support
our right to vote and secure elections
and delta's saying nah we don't we don't
support your right to vote
we support whatever outcome we want
and we're going to undermine the
integrity of elections to do it
the georgia state house should consider
getting even tougher than they are
already doing
no then they already are doing can can
we do that is it possible
for an answer to that question we turn
to dr
joe biden so say it with me
si say quad way the future is ours
thank you yes we can do it
si se podway
no no se puad way if we're talking about
jill biden joel biden was not able to do
it
the democrats have always been good at
pandering particularly on racial issues
this is why they try to sprinkle their
conversation with
spanish usually it doesn't go very well
if you watched the first couple of
presidential primary debates during 2020
on the democrat side
you would have it would have been like
you were in a sixth grade spanish
classroom
with corey booker trying to babble out
some broken spanish
beto o'rourke that was unfortunate and
isn't he spanish
he's hispanic he should be able to do it
and now joe biden butchering that
language
however you know it's funny i mentioned
the joe biden thing in part because
we for the past four years had a a
first lady who spoke something like five
languages maybe more
very elegant very urbane and the entire
left just tried to make her out to be
some kind of evil bimbo
but jill biden who she i'm not going to
attack joe biden she might be a nice
lady i don't know
but they try to make her out to be like
a rhodes scholar you know and
for a while whoopi goldberg on the view
was campaigning for her to be
the surgeon general because she didn't
know what kind of
degree joe biden had and so anyway just
just to note the double standard to the
question though
that joe biden i guess is trying to
allude to can we do it i want to i want
to apply that question
here in the question of the
woke companies can we as conservatives
say no to the companies can we say
hey you've gone too far you're trying to
undermine our system
and we're not going to let you do that
and we are going to wield the power of
the state
when the people have given it to us
against the allegedly free market
i think that phrase has been stretched
beyond all meaning
recently but can we wield the power of
the state as conservatives
to undermine the working of the free
market when those actors in the free
market are trying to subvert our
republic
my answer c say broadway si puadue mucho
mucho muimui i don't know i don't speak
spanish any better than joe biden does
of course we can conservatives
by writing a blank check to the
corporations
we have given away the game because have
you noticed that the big corporations
around the country
are pretty into woke politics have you
noticed that there are some of the
leaders
in terms of pushing woke-ism around our
country
why would we let them get away with that
because we've made some idol
out of a misbegotten conception of free
markets i love free markets
in their proper place toward the actual
end of politics
the free markets are not the end of my
politics they're an instrument
toward a good polity toward a
flourishing regime toward justice which
james madison says in the federalist
is the end of government c say puad way
sipua muimui
speaking of childish spanish gensake
was just asked a very difficult question
and she didn't have a very good answer
what's going on at the southern border
right now
is that coyotes are hurling hispanic
children
over the border uh peter ducey
brings this question up to jen saki says
hey you know your border policies don't
seem to be working that well
if it's if it's incentivizing criminal
cartels
to just hurl children across the border
what are you guys doing about that
on immigration has the white house
considered beefing up border security
now that there is
video of a three-year-old and a
five-year-old being
thrown over the wall in new mexico
beefing up border security well there
are there's video now of
a three-year-old i've seen the video and
i think any of us who saw the video
um were incredibly alarmed by
the steps of smugglers ones that we have
been quite familiar with that we've
spoken out about our concerns
about as secretary mayorka said the
inhumane way smugglers abuse children
while profiting off parents desperation
is criminal
and morally reprehensible president
certainly agrees with that
oh good i'm glad to hear that the
president agrees with that
but why is he still pursuing policies
that encourage the behavior
if you've got effectively an open border
if you're
pursuing catch and release if you're
saying the kids get to stay
then what do you think is going to
happen the coyotes are going to start
throwing the kids over the border
they're making a lot of money doing this
there was a coyote just the other day
told univision business is booming
the president of mexico blamed joe biden
for what's going on
everyone in the country is blaming joe
biden for this but biden doesn't want to
take responsibility
it's quite clear while the border has
always been an issue things have gotten
much much worse under biden because
biden said come here
come surge get over here so
jen you know he might have the best of
intentions
but look at what's going on look at what
his policies are actually resulting in
what's your answer to it jen these kids
i believe
were rescued from by uh by um
individuals who are working at the
border yes but they
still got close enough as you guys are
talking about addressing root causes in
the region for a smuggler to throw them
over a wall into the desert and i'm just
curious what
the white house is doing to stop that
from happening
and are you concerned more about the
kids safety or are you concerned about
kids getting in or tell me more about
your concern here kid safety
is as you just mentioned the main
concern well
of course it is which is why i'm often
surprised by some of the line of
questioning here but
uh i will say that our concern and our
focus
is on sending a clear message to
smuggler
to the region that uh this is not the
time to come
not the time to come not not the time to
come
we want to send a very clear message
about this issue of violating our laws
and
we want to send a very clear message
wait until next week
come on come on man a ver this is a very
clear message we are not going to
tolerate this sort of thing
until at least 2 p.m today
so just don't you know hey come on we're
being serious come on man
the that's not even the most egregious
part of that exchange
peter ducey asked the very serious
question why are we allowing these
criminals to get close enough to hurl
three-year-olds over the wall
in gensake she says well hold on peter
is your concern
the law or is your concern the safety of
the children i want to know about your
concern
i don't care about peter ducey's concern
why
why should anybody care about peter
ducey's
inner most concerns and motivations i
care about the question he's asking
which is the actual policy well yeah but
what are you what are your intentions
what are your feelings
peter first of all by the way
you can both be concerned about the
safety of the children and the safety
of the american people and the
enforcement of our laws that were passed
through
the democratic process here in the
country that at one time was governed
underneath under a constitution you can
be concerned about all i'm concerned
about the whole thing
jen why is it that it's only permissible
to be concerned about the little
children
but it's not permissible to be concerned
about
the enforcement of the law conservatives
sometimes fall into making these
arguments too
which is if you're talking about say the
injustice of affirmative action policies
that you know disadvantage white and
asian students in college and job
applications
and give an unfair advantage to black
and hispanic students
sometimes you will hear people say look
it's actually it's really it's unfair
to the the students who get the
advantage because then they'll be it'll
be
they'll be looked at as though they
didn't deserve to get in
that will follow them their career it's
it's the soft bigotry of low
expectations it's really unfair to them
sure okay it's so it is also unfair to
the people it's
disadvantaging yes it's true that what's
going on at the border
is unfair to these children it's
creating awful incentives and it's bad
to put kids in cages yeah that's true
that is bad
it's also unfair to the american people
and it's not it's not illegitimate
to to mention the concerns of the
american people
and the enforcement of our laws
the only interest jen saki has the only
pseudo argument she can make
is about motivations and intentions
and psychobabble speaking of
dubious motivations on another
major issue of public safety and public
health
the vaccines chris cuomo fredo cuomo on
cnn
had lyanna wen on dr liana wen
was the former president of planned
parenthood and she was booted out i
believe for not being radical enough on
abortion
she was she was radical enough to become
the president of planned parenthood but
but
not so radical that they that she would
go
as far as the organization wanted to go
which really tells you some
spooky stuff about that organization
leanna nguyen
hate to have to say something sort of
nice about her she was
fairly honest on television she said the
quiet part out loud about the left's
maniacal push unconstitutional push
to get everyone at all times immediately
to get the vaccine and to prove to
everybody that they got the vaccine
as she said that time is running out to
to force everyone to do this because
ultimately they're probably not going to
need to
we need to make it clear to them that
the vaccine is the ticket back to
pre-pandemic life
and the window to do that is really
narrowing i mean you were mentioning
chris about how
all these states are reopening they're
reopening at 100
and we have a very narrow window to tie
reopening
policy to vaccination status because
otherwise if
everything is reopened then what's the
carrot going to be
how are we going to incentivize people
to actually get the vaccine so that's
why i think the cdc and the obama
administration needs to come out a lot
bolder and say if you're vaccinated you
can do
all these things here all these freedoms
that you have because otherwise
people are going to go out and enjoy
these freedoms anyway
heaven forfeit we enjoy our freedoms
anyway without her permission really i
don't mean to beat up on her too much
here she's
at least blowing the whistle on what the
public health apparatus believes and
what the left believes
what's the stick going to be what's the
carrot going to be
what's the carrot going to be she's
saying that the states are going to
reopen to 100
that just is happening and the
left is pretending that the state's
reopening to 100
is contingent upon 100 of people getting
the vaccine
but liana wen admits that's not really
true
that's just a lie a noble lie that the
public health left
is telling people right now
in this narrow window before the states
reopened to 100
i don't have any interest in getting the
vaccine not because
i'm afraid that the vaccine is going to
kill me
not because i'm afraid that the vaccine
is going to inject me in 5g
or something going around frankly i
could use the extra cell service right
so i'm not i'm not totally concerned
about that
it's because i'm making a prudential
calculation of risk
which is that i'm young i think i'm
healthy
i'm not saying i'm invincible there's a
chance that i could
very very small chance but there is a
chance i could suffer some real awful
complication
from kovid and i'm going to roll the
dice
okay if i were 85 maybe i would think
differently
and liana wen and the public health
apparatus are saying you need you must
get the vaccine
we're gonna force you to get the vaccine
if you don't get the vaccine you're not
gonna be allowed to engage in commerce
which by the way is convincing me
more and more that i i'm not interested
in getting the vaccine
if if i'm going to be told that i'm
going to be ostracized from society
not because of any medical necessity but
because of the political
desires of these people when you talk
about sticks and carrots
when you talk about public the public
side of public health you're talking
about politics
and i think these these people's
politics
just totally whack and i'm not not
interested in indulging that at all
i do appreciate it when our political
opponents
tell us what they want tell us what they
think when your opponents tell you what
they're after you should believe them
even if it is someone like the former
director of planned parenthood
even if it's someone like dr fauci who
has admitted
that he was not exactly truthful on the
masks
can i say can i just say he lied when he
came out initially and said
the masks don't do anything don't wear
the masks and then later on said you
need to wear the masks they do a lot and
then he was asked why he flipped and he
said well you know part of it is the
science change but really the reason i
flipped is i wanted to save the masks
for the nurses
and so i d if i told people that the
masks worked
then they would all go out and buy them
and we wouldn't be able to save them for
the people i wanted to have them
that's all politics i i i don't agree
with most of what these people are
saying
but when they tell you what they believe
believe them
speaking of medications the trial
of derek chovin the officer involved in
the death of george floyd
is going on right now now i'm using my
words carefully i'm not saying the
officer who killed george floyd
or the officer involved involved in the
killing george floyd i'm saying
he was there at the death and the
question is
did this police officer murder george
floyd
did he accidentally kill george floyd or
did george floyd
suffer a drug overdose did he resist
arrest
well we know he resisted arrest we know
he was on drugs we know that he asked to
be taken out of the car we know
all of those things just from video so
what was the cause of death
already the left thinks that this this
cop is going to get off and you know if
the if there's justice
the left seems to think that the cop
will get off because they're they're
preemptively saying he there shouldn't
even be a trial
we we should just pay money to the
family of george floyd and the other
race hustlers who are trying to exploit
this situation we
we're bracing for riots we're bracing
for why because you think he's going to
get off why do you think he's going to
get off well for instance
because george floyd's girlfriend
admitted on the stand yesterday
that george floyd had a very very bad
drug habit
and a drug habit that was so bad that he
did
overdose within two months of his death
which may or may not have been caused by
an overdose
we went to the hospital a couple times
in march okay
um he was hot hospitalized and for a
more extended period of time in march
right
yes that's the incident i'm talking
about okay
i went to go pick floyd up from his
house
that night um i thought i was taking him
to work
he wasn't feeling good his stomach
really hurt he was doubled over in pain
um just wasn't feeling well and he said
he had to go to the hospital
so i took him straight to the hospital
um we went to the er
and um they were checking him out
in the er and um
it was getting late and i had to get
home to my son so i left
that friday night you later learned that
that was uh
due to an overdose yes
[Music]
so it goes on
more and more evidence that george floyd
died of a drug overdose
i mean even just the report of the
toxicity in his blood he had
very very toxic levels of drugs in his
blood
uh this is i'd like to stake out a third
position here between
george floyd is the worst person in the
world and he got what he deserved
and this cop killed george floyd and you
know he needs to go to jail forever or
something like that
what if it's the case that george floyd
resisted arrest took a bunch of drugs
overdosed that this cop has been
wrongly maligned whatever happened in
the moment that he's
what people are accusing of doing he
didn't do and what if one can
sort of feel bad for george floyd
but george floyd robbed a pregnant woman
at gunpoint yeah he doesn't sound like a
good guy he does not
sound like a good guy at all but what if
one can feel
sort of bad for george floyd in that the
the drug addiction that he obviously had
is just the clearest representation
of vice and sin
and broken human nature this guy
was obviously not totally in control of
what he did he's an addict i know that
in the modern liberal view
being able to pursue your base desires
is considered the definition of freedom
but it's not it's the opposite of
freedom it's licentiousness
and it compromises your free will and it
it compromises your ability
to control yourself and your desires and
it
compromises your rational faculties and
that's a very sad thing
it's why we shouldn't let druggies
completely off the hook and say well
it's not your fault no it kind of is
your fault
you know maybe maybe it's a vicious
cycle maybe you had bad circumstances
and then you turn to drugs and then you
further
impaired your will and then you couldn't
get out of it maybe it's a bad cycle and
you're somewhat responsible
but you've also compromised your free
will during that
what if that's the case i'm thinking of
this this matt gates thing
here and matt gates speaking of
potential crimes
is uh being accused of all sorts of
things but
right now the latest that's come out is
that he allegedly paid hookers
using electronic apps and
and he i'm not even saying he did this a
long time ago he did apparently
according to the allegations he did this
like two or three years ago i don't know
if it's true or not i don't i generally
don't believe things in the new york
times but
we certainly have seen this kind of
behavior with other politicians elliot
spitzer
paying hookers while in office well i
think he was prosecuting
people for prostitution a katie hill all
sorts of
weird sex crimes while she was running
for office and in office
bob menendez all sorts of weird sex
allegations and
and i think underage prostitutes in the
case of of him and his allegations
uh while he was a sitting senator
i mention all of this especially today
on good friday
because the thing that strikes us about
all these i'm not even just singling out
matt gates i don't know if those are
true or not but but all these
allegations and sometimes proven crimes
of politicians
you look at them and you you're not
really astounded
that they would give in to sins of the
flesh that's
that's actually not what surprises me
didn't surprise me about katie hill
doesn't surprise me about any of these
guys
we're kind of fleshy beings and we have
these desires
i'm no more surprised at that than i
would be surprised that a fat guy gives
into eating a cupcake
but what surprises you is that someone
with this kind of power
bob kraft you know super rich sports
team owner
goes to a massage parlor in jupiter why
why would you why are you doing it
you have everything and yet you give in
to this really basic
base desire genesis
chapter 4 verse 7 sin
is crouching at your door and it desires
you
it's there it's it's there it's always
there waiting to devour you
and it doesn't matter how big and
powerful
and rich and famous you get in some ways
you're more susceptible to it
then and it doesn't matter how old it's
not like you know when you're a kid you
make
all these mistakes but then you become
an adult and you don't have to worry
about this anymore you do
you of course do the the thing that's
interesting to me about the matt gates
allegations or really any of the other
you know proven crimes we've seen from
politicians is
how stupid it seems from the outside
perspective
but how persuasive it must have been for
these people in this moment
the hubris it has to involve the lust
that it has to involve
the lack of self-control that it has to
involve
like an addiction you know we are
reminded that the man who sins
is a slave to sin any coherent
understanding of liberty
in the american context or in any
context
has to start from there has to start
from this distinction
between licentiousness and liberty
because if we can continue to conflate
the two
we're going to lose our liberty uh more
and more and more and more and and we're
not going to need some woke
corporation to undermine our political
liberty we will have done it ourselves
we're not going to need to to focus only
on delta or coca-cola
or some crazy blue hairs or anything
like that
we even as conservatives even as
republicans
will will have done it ourselves are we
going to continue to have
intellect and will as conservatives are
we going to try to
to pull that back from the bizarre silly
shallow philosophy we've embraced over
the last 20 or so years
my answer is cece podway si sipuadwei
mui mui mucho mucho ben is going to be
talking about this
on his show the woca cola nonsense and
also aoc's plan to spend 10 trillion
dollars
also you got to check out candace's show
the candice show is coming up
the show is available exclusively to
daily wire members so if you are not a
member yet go to dailywire.com
subscribe use code canvas to get 25 off
that's code candace for 25
off join now so you can tune in friday
night for a closer look we will be right
back
with the mailbag
welcome back my absolute favorite time
of the week
beginning with nicholas dear michael you
talk a lot about gnostic
dualism and how it relates to
transgenderism
could you give an explanation in detail
of what exactly
the heresy is and why it is such
but without the parallels to the
transgender movement thanks love the
show can't wait for the new book oh
thank you very much yes gladly
wow oh my gosh you've just reminded me
this must be the longest i've gone
without plugging my new book
in in weeks the new book by the way
titled speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now for
pre-order and you can also pre-order an
autographed copy at premier collectibles
great question on gnostic dualism so
gnostic dualism has taken many forms
over the
millennia one of the clearest versions
of this would be manichaeism
this battle between good and evil and
the evil of this world and the good of
the
eternal realm you see a kind of softer
version of this
in a revival of manichaeism which
occurred a little over a millennium
later
in the rise of albigensianism also known
as catharism
what all of these versions have in
common
is that the physical world is evil and
the metaphysical world
is good and so we need to oppose the
physical world it lends itself to a sort
of asceticism
and we need to only embrace the truth of
the metaphysical world
this is why we use this term gnosticism
is because what you see what we all
sense this war and perceive this world
to be is not
true according to this philosophy that
actually there's a secret knowledge
that's where
the word gnostic means right secret
knowledge
that uh really tells you the truth so
i look like a boy the parallel to
transgenderism then is
i look like a boy but secretly i
know that i'm a girl so
so therefore it's not just an open
question am i a boy as i appear or am i
a girl as i secretly know deep down
somewhere
what gnostic dualism would posit is
physical world always bad
metaphysical world purely good but the
reality of the situation is that
god who exists outside of time and space
creates this whole physical world that
we have around us
through this this loving act of speech
and the the words that god with which
god speaks the universe into creation
is god the word is god the divine logic
of the universe the logos is god and
then the bond of unity between the
father and the son
is so substantial that he is a third
person which makes up the trinity
the physical world is created good but
goes bad
through the fall of man through the
disobedience of adam in the garden to
turn away from god and to disobey and
then man is
kicked out and sin and death pervade the
world
however that's not the end of the story
the
line that we celebrate on easter is
the the felix culpa o happy fault
that won for us so great so glorious a
redeemer
that god in his providence even though
the world goes
so so bad becomes incarnate
sends his only begotten son and so the
second person of the of the trinity
becomes a man fully
human fully divine and dies on the cross
today on good friday
and really dies and on the cross
in his death repays this this debt
this infinite debt repays it
and redeems mankind and
descends into hell heroes hell rises
again from the dead
ascends up into heaven to see that the
god at the right hand of god the father
almighty shall come again to judge
living in the dead and his kingdom will
have no end that's the
that's a great question for good friday
from justine hey michael
do you think men of italian descent make
for a better mate
if so what qualities make them better
i'm a little bit biased in this question
but i'm going to try to give you as
objective and answer as i can
yes absolutely 100 there's no question
about it
why i will acknowledge there are some
downsides to italian men
we are well i think this is an upside
but today would be considered a downside
we tend to be a little more old-school
okay of all the immigrant groups that
ever came to america basically the only
one that ever turned out conservative
were the italians cubans too though
that's weakening over time
the italians by and large a pretty
conservative group that came over here a
little more old school
we're probably not going to be you know
mr mom
okay we're probably not going to get up
and do the dishes all the time
clean up the house we're okay that and
that is you know that's unfortunate
sometimes
however italian men beyond our immense
charm
and physical attractiveness and things
like that good cooks
so we actually you know do cook a little
bit of the time
uh very passionate make of that what you
will
a very very sentimental italian men you
know we put on a good stern exterior
very very loving people give someone
think of the greatest love poetry ever
written
think of dante think of petrarch
oh my gosh we are we are just so in love
we are so you know we we
i i'm speechless i'm left speechless by
that so yes i think italian men do make
a good mate
um i will say just i know my wife
listens to this show i don't want her to
get the wrong idea i am taken but there
are lots of italian men out there
and so i wish that you will find your
your perfect match from joshua
dear michael knowles i understand that
you do not enjoy
marijuana yourself it's never been your
personal thing
i do know you drink and use tobacco so
do i but i'm wondering how
you can morally advocate for the
legalization
of alcohol and tobacco when they have
similar if not more harmful effects than
marijuana
this is probably the only area i
disagree with you on love the show will
continue watching regardless of the
answer
well i'm not advocating for the
legalization of alcohol and
tobacco those two things are legal
and marijuana is now increasingly
legal but it's still broadly illegal so
we're not start we're not beginning from
the same place
one mistake that liberals make and when
i say liberals i mean
liberal republicans and and liberal
democrats
is they think that everything is
abstract
they're they're only looking at the
alcohol or the tobacco or the marijuana
but i'm actually
looking at them in reality in the
practical tradition that we have
alcohol and tobacco are already legal i
don't see any reason to make them
illegal
they are heavily regulated i'm not
totally against that
i do wish i could still smoke my cigar
in bars somewhere but you know
unfortunately mike bloomberg ruined that
but okay
that's fine i'm talking about the real
practical tradition whereas marijuana
is different it's a bad thing i don't
think it does anything good for the
culture
now you might say michael that's not a
perfectly abstract
rationalist argument right i don't think
we should be making
abstract rationalist arguments primarily
in politics i think we should be making
prudential practical arguments in
politics
there is an another cultural aspect here
which is that tobacco has been a part of
our culture for a very long time
500 years or so it's been a part of
american culture you know before
columbus discovered america it's been a
part of american culture for a very very
long time
now we live in america there's a little
blending of culture there and alcohol
has always been part of our culture
christ's first miracle
is turning water into wine i just don't
think
speaking of rationalist abstraction i
don't think
it's a good idea to try to uproot these
very important things from our culture
and i don't know that we could do it
even if we tried
i think that's part of why prohibition
failed but i don't think that
marijuana prohibition necessarily would
fail we kept marijuana illegal for a
really long time and i think that's
perfectly fine
or we can slowly start to regulate it
okay i mean i'm not gonna
not going to flee the country because of
that but i just don't think it's
good and i think that we are absolutely
entitled in our republic to
have a vision of the good and a vision
of the true and a vision of the
beautiful
vision of what's right and to express
that vision through our elected
representatives in laws and i don't
think there's anything wrong with that
particularly when that those sorts of
expressions and those regulations
are at the more local level from nick
michael i've been struggling with my
faith for a number of years now
i was brought up as a christian but have
had a lot of exposure to a lot of
different religions during my formative
years
this caused me to have many unanswered
questions regarding what i should and
shouldn't believe
being raised in the church i want to
believe in god but i just can't seem to
fully commit could you please give me
some insight as to what i should do
sure i can recommend a bunch of books to
read i was an atheist for about 10 years
i was brought back
through certain arguments for the
existence of god the modal ontological
argument got me as formulated by alvin
plantinga
the two mystic arguments are very
persuasive from saint thomas aquinas
the book mere christianity by c.s lewis
did a lot for me
but it depends what aspect you're going
after you know for me
the hang-up was intellectual pride and
so the way back in was
an intellectual way back in if the
hang-up for you
is more i don't know emotional or
something like that then you'll have a
different way in if it's more liturgical
you'll have a different way
you should know that god exists the
existence of god is knowable
by the light of reason from the natural
world so there
there's just there's a lot of good
arguments for god and there are no good
arguments against god but that might not
bring you all the way you might not say
well okay i
acknowledge god exists but you know does
that mean christianity is true well you
what are the arguments for christianity
the really historical arguments
christological considerations here right
you know
the nature of christ himself what christ
means
but drew clavin has a great answer on
this which is that if you can't bring
yourself to believe in god
just behave as though you do for 60 days
pray behave in your personal life and
that will start to happen access to the
sacraments
is very important here and i think it's
important
not to fall into either of
two heresies i don't think you should
fall into the heresy of
skepticism that we just can't know about
these things for certain
which is a very popular heresy right now
but i also don't think you should fall
into the heresy of fideism
that reason is totally useless and we
just got to believe our bible darn it
even if it contradicts reason
the bible does not contradict reason by
the way the the truth of the matter is
that
we can know these things through reason
and also revelation
tells us quite a lot um but the faith is
reasonable
and and you should know that if you have
any more specifics on this i'd be happy
to answer a further question
from yar dear michael have you gotten
more into guns than shooting since
leaving california
no actually i haven't unexpectedly
i i got into guns and shooting in
california
i got it i bought my first gun because
the government told me i couldn't so
then i bought the gun they told me i
couldn't buy
i was much more into it there here i'm
i'm kind of more laid back
i'm more relaxed i also have less time
because i've got my sweet little
screaming bundle of joy 24 7.
so uh you know one one does not have as
much time to head on over to the range
but you know i'm interested i wanna i
wanna get more into it here
but i do think this is this is true more
broadly in politics
i i think much more about
very particular political questions when
i'm surrounded by my opponents
because i have to because the bullets
are flying all the time and so i've got
to really consider down to the
nitty-gritty
i think the same is true with with all
manner of behavior you think much more
about your second amendment rights
when you're in a place that you you know
there's no
right real right for you to have it or
the right is really threatened
it's you're much more conscious of it
when you're in a place where you're
under fire
from spencer dear michael first i wanted
to say congratulations for becoming a
father thank you very much
my question is this do you think the
public school system will
pull back with their woke agenda anytime
in the near future
at least enough for very conservative
parents like my wife and i
to be comfortable and confident our
daughter won't be subjected to all the
critical race theory and gender ideology
nonsense we are middle class we don't
know if we'll be able to afford private
school
when our daughter is starting school
we'd love to hear your thoughts yeah
this is a big issue i'm i'm
grappling with this too no i don't think
the public school system is going to get
any better anytime soon
the problems of the public school system
have been
built in from the beginning it goes way
way back many decades ago to john dewey
it goes back
well over a century and a half ago or
more to horus mann
there was always this progressive
character to it your best hope i would
suspect
is to move somewhere sorry to say this i
know that's not cheap either
but your best hope is probably to move
somewhere
where the public schools are just less
decayed at this point but it's very
tricky
this is how they get you because the
public schools are free the private
schools are extremely expensive and
homeschooling is expensive too because
it's
expensive with your time last question
from mike hey michael do you think that
sleepy joe is so sleepy because he can't
sleep at night knowing that corn pop is
still out there well
mike great question corn pop is a very
bad dude
so that would not surprise me at all
great question to end on
hope you all have a blessed and holy
good friday
and holy saturday and happy easter and
i'll see you on monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nikka geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin